[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
photos - gratuité de jeunes à dire un
jour le grand yaka a voulu aller à
l'achat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui nous pouvons danser
[Musique]
tiens tiens
que faites vous là dégourdis sont les
pâtes aussi avec moi parce kg
d'autrefois bérénice pour le mama ordres
du grand yaka jean bène titus nous
allons à la chasse à la sauce lourd l'on
écoute move cas premièrement voulait pas
de permis de chasse
deuxièmement venait pas de fusil et
troisièmement je préfère danser avec
bernier et quatrièmement le grand yakata
temps et tu dois me suivre titus bonbons
c'est le grand écart qui commande alors
allons à la face au
aujourd'hui je me sens en forme je
verrai tous et d'un seul coup de fusil
est là quand y'a pas ne tirez pas vous
suit votre petit lion approche après
titus approche vous ferait grand bien
tard il ne faut pas plaisanter avec ce
jour où un essai les pages où c'était
fusil n'y aura on me plaît et je suis un
grand chasseur tue ses titres
tu vas voir ce que je sais faire avec un
bon physique comme celui d'un fils moi
qu'est-ce que je fais toi tu es de mosca
a placé du gibier de 20 mois à l'est
dépêchez-vous là ça se bat comme elle
c'est par ici
titus vient d'aider à régler la hauteur
on fasse ici dans le palais évidemment
le grand yaka reste assis dans son
fauteuil et nous qu'est ce que nous
faisons nous lui posons le lapin un ceux
ci haut pour prouver le lapin compte sur
moi alors seul appel il est vrai grand
yaka votre lapin est avancé il carton
nous il va tirer
attention je tire
dis-donc mosca
nous l'avons échappé belle et le lapin
est toujours debout
il a bougé il
résister aux petits lapins mais ce coup
ci il va sauter en l'air
didon mosca il est dangereux ce bonhomme
oui titus mais que faire
il a encore vous et cela paie il a peur
de moi est ici que je suis le plus beau
mois le grand yaka
je vais les transformé en passoire des
cinq coups de fusils il alors il ne part
pas du coup se fusionnent ils marchent
plus quoi titus bien voir mon fusil il
ne fait plus bon veut vraiment occupé
grand ya pas voir alors je vois veut
voir c'est facile à comprendre
il n'y a plus de cartouches mais alors
titus tu as trouvé la parade
oui grand yaka voilà votre fusil n'aime
pas le lapin et il ne peut plus tirer
mais moi je me sens et de la paix je
vais encore chasser je veux m'amuser la
maigre en rit encore vous pouvez
s'affaissant flavie tenez prenez ce
filet à papillons aux messines ronsin et
tu crois que j'attrape heures elle l'a
fait avec ça je vous le garantis vous
l'aurez du premier coup avec vous mon
prix regardez bien comment il faut faire
attention veut vivre et rope retient et
voilà grand yaka comment on fait la paix
bravo tu l'as eu du premier coup
titus qui est un grand chasseur et je
veux chasser comme toi c'est bien
agréable de se sentir vivant et après
après c'est une autre histoire
[Applaudissements]